le populisme secoue l'amérique et il
parcourt l'occident pourquoi
s'arrêterait-il aux frontières du canada
où un citoyen sur cinq selon ce sondage
crop aimerait bien d'un trompe à la tête
du pays depuis la publication de ce
sondage à multiples volets celui sur les
perceptions et désirs des canadiens par
rapport au populisme fait l'objet de
grands débats
je pense que le populisme du côté
politique c'est une réponse simple et
complexe
alain giguère et président de la firme
de sondage crop auteurs de ce sondage
pour radio canada sur l'immigration et
le populisme
on vit dans une société qui se
transforme constamment le raid de
transformation est difficile pour
certains à s'adapter et donc le
populisme c'est le politicien qui
arrivent et qui prétend avoir des
solutions simples tous ces problèmes de
jeu c'est vrai que 20% pour monsieur
trempe c'est peut-être pas beaucoup
moi je pense que ça cache que ça cache
si on regarde l'ensemble de ces
résultats là je pense que de la place
pour un policier qui serait carrément
populiste mais peut-être moins
caricaturale que monsieur 30 trempé trop
caricatural par rapport à nos valeurs
c'est pour ça qu'ils recueillent juste
20%
[Applaudissements]
le type de discours populiste de droite
qu'on n'est pas à l'abri de souk al
zaïdi depuis très longtemps on parle par
exemple parti l'alliance du parti
réformiste qui venaient de l'ouest au
canada qui était un père critiquer
visite étant perçus comme étant des
diètes qui venait de commander du canada
faveur de l'ontario du québec fuyuki
cours à sawa professeur au département
de sociologie de l'université york à
toronto on n'a pas le même livre ou de
polarisation ce comics aux états unis
même si c'est quand on n'est pas à
l'abri de ça non plus au canada il est
un peu différent celui des états unis il
n'y a pas vraiment eu non plus de
montenescourt des nobles islamophobe
entre quoi qui est devenue partie
prenante de parti politique donc c'est
sûr que il faut toujours être à l'aidant
à léguer la réparation mais qu' il ya
des conditions qui sont différentes il
faut des canadiens dire est il vraiment
non un leader à la donne trempe
déjà je crois qu'il faut une vision
partout on voit bien les élections
néerlandaise cette semaine les élections
françaises qui vont venir le mois
prochain ce qui s'est passé aux états
unis
benjamin haddad et chercheur au brussels
institute à washington parce qu'on le
voit en fait il faut être lucide aussi
sur les faillites des élites qui sont
dénoncées par les populistes est vrai
que dans un pays comme les etats unis
on a vu quels impacts de la crise
économique
on a vu le décrochage d'une partie de la
population à cause de la
désindustrialisation dans certaines
zones
on voit en europe le chômage ou les
failles de l'union européenne ce que
font les populistes en revanche c'est
qu'il détourne cette frustration qui
peut être légitime c'est il met le doigt
sur un échec qui réel mais le détourne
vers un discours de fermeture de repli
un discours nationaliste
je crois que vous avez deux phénomènes
vous avez le populisme mais vous avez
aussi le nationalisme et le challenge
pour les hommes politiques libéraux pour
les modérés pour ceux qui ont envie
justement de se réapproprier ce discours
politique c'est de réussir à offrir une
réponse une nouvelle offre qui certes
reconnaît l'échec
une partie des politiques qui ont été
menées mais qui arrive à prôner
l'ouverture
apprenez la réforme intelligente les
scénarios et les définitions
s'affrontent donc d'un d'un dans cette
perspective là justement ils vont dans
l'état de court circuiter certains
aspects de la démographie victor armony
du centre de recherche
interdisciplinaire en diversité et en
démocratie d'université du québec à
montréal parle d'une remontée du
populisme dans les systèmes
démocratiques du monde
un populisme qui est souvent confondue
par la population avec la démocratie
elle-même et se tourne vers soi des
leaders charismatiques l'udc qui
promettent la lune ou qui font des
discours parfois très chargé de symbole
mais peu substantielle au niveau du
contenu ou justement vont suivre ce qui
se positionne contre le système lui même
donc paradoxalement la démocratie est en
train de faire lire des figures quelque
part un petit démocratique et voilà un
paradoxe qui à la fois montre on
pourrait dire la force la vitalité de la
démocratie parce que les gens arrivent à
faire élire un justement ce qu'il
souhaite mais en même temps ce sont des
façons de faire qui en dernière instance
en tout cas je crois affaiblissent les
bases de la démocratie qu'est ce que
c'est bon c'est le raccourci
intellectuel c'est oublier certaine
réalité factuelle c'est de mettre en
lumière petits détails qui veilla
deviennent gros c'est un peu seul
populisme gérard deltell est un député
du comté de louis saint laurent au
québec et il représente le parti
conservateur du canada
mais la grande distinction que l'on doit
avoir en tête c'est que le populisme n'a
pas de droite ou de gauche
le populisme appartient à des
politiciens qui peuvent avoir parfois
des envies de sombrer dans ce type de
raccourcis mais il est très délicat et
très fragile de vouloir identifier telle
ou telle personne ou telle ou telle
politique et en la qualifiant de
populistes comme ça pour lui envoyer un
seuil de cochonneries dans la fin j'ai
personnellement été victime dune
d'une attaque particulièrement vicieuse
en pleine chambre des communes ya trois
semaines alors qu'un député de l'onta
lukman jamais écoutées en france et est
allé dire que parce que j'avais déjà
donné des entrevues à des postes de
radio de québec j'avais généré moi même
j'avais contribué à générer le climat
conduisant la tragédie de québec c'était
indécent c'est très populaire s'était
savait pas de bon sens qui est dit là
mais il le dit pareil quand même des
gens côté de vue que le nom applaudi à
travers tout cela ce qui fait monter
comme des bulles de champagne le
populisme à la surface au canada c'est
certainement l'opinion qu'ont les
simples citoyens par rapport aux médias
dans lequel on ne fait plus vraiment
confiance est de moins en moins
confiance c'est ce que confirmait le
sondage crop
un reportage de radio canada
international